this is the entrance of the APAC let's
just feel around here so you the crowd
of supporters chanting so there we go
they just broke the barricades these
American Jews are shutting down the
biggest pro-israel event in the United
States the American Israel Public
Affairs Committee conference
I feel heartbroken that it's taken this
much to get our people to move I feel
angry and I feel hopeful I feel hopeful
I feel hopeful look at these beautiful
humans here their group is called if not
now if not now came out of the summer of
2014 or so response to the Gaza war and
I think a larger transformation of my
generation of Judaism and a shift of
consciousness to what it means to be
Jewish and what it means to support
Israel I feel angry and I feel empowered
and I'm not letting the people inside
that building speak for me anymore but
not everybody was on their side the
Jewish Defense League also showed up
support Israel's right to exist what do
you make of all these people here
Hippocrates there's no such a thing
called extubation I am Palestinian
myself I'm Palestinian as well and my
family lives under occupation and polish
no Palestine Palestinian or liar today
how are you Palestinian I belong to your
opinion
they're farming but there's not okay so
a very very confusing scene here and the
league's members provoked AIPAC
protesters and even burned a hood on but
despite being physically attacked and
called Nazis Kappas and more the if not
now activists remained remarkably calm
it shows immense promise for the future
and I invite everyone in older
generations to follow our lead as the
future of a community because honestly I
don't think that there will be a
beautiful flourishing future for the
Jewish community here in the US unless
our older folks come with us and join
you